Water
Earth
Fire
Air
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Mike and Bryan
revealed a first look at their new avatar The Last
Airbender animated movie that's coming out in 2025
so we'll break it all down also explain what's
happening with the brand new avatar The Last
Airbender animated series that are starting to
come out that same year as well as the live-action
Netflix avatar The Last Airbender series which is
coming out later this year too so there's a lot
of avatar coming to our TV screens in the next
couple of years of course I will do videos for
everything if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all those videos I'll do
a special giveaway when we start getting episodes
later this year too but at cinemacon this week
they revealed an actual first look at the brand
new avatar The Last Airbender animated movie that
Mike and Bryan are doing it's meant to tee up
the big Avatar universe that they're expanding
basically when they announced they were coming
back to the project to the series they were going
to be making a bunch more TV series set in the
universe and a bunch more movies as well but all
in the Animated Universe all the live action stuff
that's completely separate that's Netflix stuff
the very first movie they're doing doing is about
the adult gang as you can see here set after the
events of book three the funny thing about this is
it actually doesn't look too different from a lot
of the fan art that we've seen from everybody the
last several years one of the notable differences
though is that Aang does not have a beard and he
does have a beard in all the adult eggs that we
see during Korra during those episodes he was
actually closer to the end of his life closer to
his 40s looking at that epic ponytail that Zuko
has how much older guitar looks I would say
they're within 10 years older than the end of
book 3. like very early 20s Aang even though
technically his body is much much older they
didn't say who the villain's going to be but
they're not doing the exact plot of the comics
but they did say that the plot of the comics will
start to become Canon for the most part it's all
meant to be Canon if you haven't read any of those
the comics basically tell you exactly what happens
to them right after the finale like Aang and
Fire Lord Zuko create Republic City or they start
creating Republic City takes a while to build it
Azula comes back to harass Zuko doing exactly what
you would expect Azula to do they explained who
toph's baby daddies are she had two different baby
daddies and they explained what happened to Zuko's
mother I've already done a couple videos about all
that stuff so I'll post links for that stuff in
the description below and really the only thing
that you don't get from this first look scene here
is that it's actually going to be 3D animation
that'll probably be the biggest difference from
all the previous Avatar series which were 2D
animation they did say that for all the different
upcoming Avatar series and movies they would all
probably have slightly different animation Styles
they have about three different movies that are in
development right now the adult gaang one is
just the first one that means that all three
of those movies might have slightly different
animation Styles as well as the TV series in the
way that the original avatar The Last Airbender
series had a very different animation style from
Legend of Korra when that aired Bryan Konietzko
was recently talking about the future of Avatar
as well too now we're getting to expand the
franchise in different directions all at once
now we're making a movie our first movie
and so that always as an artist that that
was like really alluring to me I
can't really wrap my head around
the Final Mix and the final color correction on
the feature now we're talking about doing multiple
projects at the same time including feature films
it's really cool to hear him talking about Avatar
again they've been working on it for a while now
they're just really quiet about it they said that
it took them almost four years to develop the
original avatar The Last Airbender series and
they only announced the project close to about
four years ago which is why it's taking so long
for them to release all this because they're
trying to build out an entire universe but
the really good news you probably just saw in
your feeds is that Mike and Bryan's first new
remember this first new but not last new animated
avatar The Last Airbender series is now confirmed
to be about the next Avatar after akora moving the
timeline forward the same way that Korra just came
after Aang The Avatar cycle goes fire air water
and Earth so when Mike and Bryan first announced
that they were making new animated Avatar movies
and series most of us just speculated that they'd
logically just move the timeline forward and
do the next Avatar after Korra which would be
an earthbender avatar but they are also doing
stuff earlier in the timeline too like they'll
be jumping all over the timeline and a bunch of
different types of projects I'll explain later
in the video but the new Full regular animated
series will just pick up after Korra has died
in the new earthbender Avatar is born they have
it announced who the person's name is or if it's
going to be a female or a male Avatar but if
you've been following the story of Korra in the
comics that explains what happens to her after the
events of the finale her lifespan is meant to be
fairly typical of the majority of all avatars
meaning she lived Beyond 100 years old which
you would consider like a slightly longer lifespan
for a really healthy person living past 100 in the
Avatar Universe isn't uncommon for regular people
the only major exceptions to how long avatars
live are when they're either killed in battle like
killed under mysterious circumstances or the most
famous examples being Avatar kyoshi and Avatar
Aang Aang died when he was 66 chronologically
and at the time it was considered a very early
death in terms of his year spent walking around
like chronologically but biologically he died at
the age of 166 because he was stuck in the ice
for over 100 years and being in the Avatar state
for that long just took a huge toll on his body
had that not happened he would have just lived
a normal lifespan well past 100 years the other
exception like on the other end of that is Kyoshi
who lived way longer than most avatars she was
about 200 years old when she died but she was a
beast she was also just physically way bigger than
most people one of the new animated movies that
they're doing is a kyoshi movie I'll talk about
that later in the video so they are doing a lot
of new Kyoshi stuff too but the idea is that this
new earthbender Avatar series after Korra would
pick up about a hundred years after the quora
finale close to or at real world present day like
a modern day Avatar like a lot of people wondered
that they would do so the idea is that during the
events of Korra Republic City for example had a
very Roaring 20s inspired Vibe with the design
and the level of Technology the way bending had
evolved this new series would look more like our
real world present day like an avatar walking
around with our current level of Technology but
remember this is the Avatar universe so it's not
always like a one-to-one comparison like the best
example being will this new Avatar be the one who
walks around with an iPhone in his or her pocket
like The Tik Tok Avatar please don't put Tik Tok
in the Avatar Universe we could do without that
this is where I think Mike and Bryan will change
a couple things like the current period in the
Avatar universe will just be similar in the way
science starts to rival traditional use of bending
elements like during the events of Legend of Korra
their big thing was showing that just 50 years
plus after avatar The Last Airbender Society
had evolved to start harnessing lightning bending
powers to generate electricity people like kuvira
began to harness Spirit energy taken from
the vines in the world tree using them to
power weapons and Technology people like bayfong
were using their metal bending abilities to power
their technology for crime fighting like not
just their tactics but also their armor their
Weaponry what we'll probably see is more of
that kind of thinking like scientists in the
future of the Avatar Universe finding new ways
of exploiting bending energy cosmic energy from
the spirit world for weapons for technology even
for just regular everyday stuff that non-benders
use and take advantage of they started to get
into this idea during course season 4 where
some people have started to harvest abuse Spirit
energy cosmic energy the spirit world started to
fight back the spirits themselves the biological
life that originated there like the vines that
started to take over Republic City so in the way
the chorus Series in general had started to get
into the balance between bending and Technology
a modern-day Avatar series would be all about
that like the other cool thing being that every
time they do Advance the timeline the Avatar
universe is that bending in general just evolves
as people come up with more creative ways to use
their bending Powers you start to see even more
specialized forms of sub-bending let me know in
the comments what kind of sub styles of bending do
you want to see just based on what we've already
seen from sub bending Styles I know there's also
a big question about the way avatars access their
previous lives because during the events of
Korra unalaq essentially destroyed her access
to the previous lives with vaatu's dark Avatar
Powers after that Korra never got access to those
previous avatars again she could only speak with
rabba which was something that previous avatars
weren't supposed to be able to do like maybe a
few were able to but in general when Korra did it
it was not to be a relatively new thing like raava
had always been there inside the other avatars but
you never hear about Aang chatting it up with
rabba meaning that when this new earthbender
Avatar comes along a hundred years later he'd
only be able to speak with Korra Spirit or rava
unless they introduced some new weird wrinkle to
the way Avatar Powers work right now the target
release date is the end of 2025 right after the
new animated avatar The Last Airbender movie comes
out so you kind of see what they're doing here
they're going to try and release that new movie
in October 2025 and then like right after that
the series picks up the new Avatar series will
run at the same time as the live-action Netflix
series but the live-action Netflix episodes are
just retelling the events of the original avatar
The Last Airbender animated series with Aang and
by the time the new animated series premieres
will be in like season two of the live action
series and while that's happening every two or
every three years they'll release a new animated
Avatar movie they've already announced three
movies total the first one is with the adult gang
but the second two are a Zuko movie and a Kyoshi
movie they didn't say which order they're going
to do them in but I'm assuming right now it starts
with the Avatar The Last Airbender movie about the
whole gang because they've confirmed that then the
Zuko movie and then the kyoshi movie there will
be more animated movies and more animated series
after these first ones from Mike and Bryan that
probably won't talk about the other stuff till
after later seasons of this first new one though
so like this is meant to be the beginning of a
big Avatar Universe of shows from all across the
timeline so when you're all old and gray and you
have like great grandchildren you'll be telling
them about the original Avatar series as the new
one gets ready to Premiere like ah the 10th new
Avatar series can't wait to talk about it it'll
be a lot of fun they've also said that they're
evolving or changing the animation style for the
upcoming movie they'll probably do the same thing
for the Avatar TV series as well they did say that
they wanted all their upcoming projects like all
the different movies in the series to all feel and
look very different but but they did say the first
upcoming movie will feature computer assisted
animation in the style of Spider-Man into the
spider-verse like that kind of computer assisted
animation is coming from the same Studio that also
animated rise of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
which actually has pretty solid animation the
Netflix account was teasing some Avatar stuff so
they might make some more announcements or drop
a teaser video for that new live-action Netflix
series pretty soon whatever they wind up releasing
of course they'll do a video for it everyone click
here for all my avatar The Last Airbender videos
and click here for my brand new Ahsoka video
because I'll be doing episodes for that pretty
soon thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!